welcome to this second session of
interviews on the ftth conference in
stockholm with me i have hartwig tauber
the general manager of ftth council
europe
welcome hartwig
as you can see behind us it's lunch time
here in stockholm and
we are
still it's still coming in lots of
people from all around the world to this
event
the latest numbers i've heard actually
heard them just recently from eurtwig
3 000 people are here
indeed first of all thank you for
inviting me and welcome yes we have just
got the latest numbers we again reach
the 3000 people uh for the fddh
conference which makes this event the
biggest 500 home related event in the
world which makes us proud and
if we talk about numbers another number
is we have 84 different countries
represented here so the delegates are
really coming from all over the world
of course most of them from the european
side and this is for us a real big and
great success to welcome so many people
here in stockholm
and for us it's a special honor to be in
stockholm because talking about these
special things it's for the first time
that we are in a country where we don't
need to educate the people fiber is
necessary
but we are here to showcase how they use
fiber and how they use the the fiber of
the home technology to enhance their
life to get a better economy running and
even to have the environment protected
talking about all these nationalities
do you know who's
who's been traveling the longest way to
come here the longest way uh thinking
about my geographic and knowledge i
think is we have a delegation from new
zealand here in new zealand so really
from the other side of the world uh
coming over which is interesting for us
because new zealand is one of the
leading countries on fiber and still
they made the effort to come over and
see what sweden and the nordic countries
are doing on fiber networks which is i
believe a very very good sign for the
nordic countries on how
far they already had on fiber adoption
are there events like this in other
parts of the world trying to compete
with us in this event
yes they are events but they don't
compete with us so that's the good and
the
the bad news
we have uh five ftdh councils worldwide
so this is uh in addition to the fdh
council europe we have one in america's
including latin america one in asia
pacific one in middle east and one in
south africa and we as the fddh council
europe are working very closely together
to make sure that we can cover the whole
globe on
fiber adoption
and they all do an annual conference
i'm happy to say and of course proud
that the european one is the largest and
the biggest one
is there a reason why we are the largest
conference
maybe it's because of the good food that
we are offering here
it's always difficult to say i mean the
european market is quite a big market
it's still a growing market so it is
very interesting for the people to
see also what are the dynamics here but
i believe
and that's the reason why i looked at
the at the foot we try to do our
conference as a real networking event so
it's not just a conference with streams
it's not just an exhibition hall it's
really something where the people come
in stay here for two days
and can really do networking meeting
each other and just when i came in i met
a friend of mine who said heartache it's
great i have a series of meetings the
next two days which saves me nearly four
weeks of traveling because instead of
going all around europe all the people
are here and i think this is a bit of
the secret of the success of this event
which we of course will uh want to
continue also in the next years is there
a main topic at this this event except
from ftth of course
yes this year as mentioned at the
beginning the main topic is showcasing a
brighter future which means we have in
the
in the program of the of the conference
a lot of sessions where the nordic
operators the nordic organizations and
decision makers show
what they do with fiber so just now we
had one session running where
the the big operators in the nordic said
we do fiber because of this this and
this reasons we have two sessions on
gaming because a lot of people don't
know it but most of the big gaming
studios have offices here in the nordics
one of the reasons is because fiber is
here we have a session talking about
fiber can save your life so it's about
e-health care for elderly people to show
it is more than just faster internet
it's really something that changes the
way we use the broadband connections and
the good thing is
here in the nordics we don't talk what
could come in the future we simply show
what's already happening and just to
give you a small teaser tomorrow when we
talk about e-health we will have a robot
on stage who is used for taking care of
elderly people so people can really see
and touch these solutions
but but
i mean there must be a whole much future
as well as i mean
maybe we are in sweden are ahead of many
other countries but
there must be i mean
the the future
is something that is very difficult to
predict uh of course but uh this is
something we we also want to uh to tell
the people and our president cavanaugh
made it very clearly in her opening
speech when she said 30 years ago a lot
of the
business and the companies that are big
today didn't even exist and let's talk
about the next 20 30 years you don't
know what what will come and we just had
this discussion also in one of our
sessions in the program when we talk
about smart cities smart regions and
this is not just saying okay you can
control your heating from the office
which of course sometimes i would be
happy if i could switch on my oven so
that when i come home i can already put
the pizza in but this is just one thing
the other thing is to give you an
example
with fiber and really a connected world
things like autonomous cars are possible
something you couldn't imagine three
years ago today they're already driving
in in the us and so just imagine if this
is possible everywhere and taking a
country like sweden with a lot of rural
areas i myself am coming from austria so
i have the same imagine instead of
having a public transport where a huge
bus needs to go from one city to the
other you have autonomous public cars
that are connected to your agenda on
your whatever you have then smartphone
device and when you know okay i need to
go let's say uh to stockholm and i'm
somewhere outside
the car is there you just enter it and
then you will say
it sounds like future i would like to
make a bet that uh 2013 this will be
reality and we will just like today we
are connected with a smartphone which
nobody could imagine 10 years ago in 20
years we will just have this as a very
normal thing in our life and then we
will realize that fiber
and the fiber broadband really changed
the way we are living and thinking yeah
talking about this morning
you made an amazing entrance can you
just tell more about the
the beginning of this day yes this uh
this is something very special we always
do at the fddh conference that we want
to make a strong start so that people
have something to talk about and this
year as we have this super citizen so if
you look at our uh visuals you always
have the people having their
uh five of the home house here we had a
film at the beginning where we showed a
family connected to fiber
and he the the father at the end was
more or less a fiber superhero and to
underline this nadia babali our
communications director and myself
who were the moderators of the session
we not just walked on the stage we came
down the ceiling so like special forces
we are now the fddh
council uh super citizen special forces
making sure that everyone in europe gets
fiber as quick as possible oh yeah and
after after that entrance you had four
swedish speakers that must be the first
time ever you have four speakers four
beginning speakers from one in the same
country indeed and the reason for this
one and that's we are really proud of is
that sweden
is the country where fiber is happening
so the decision makers and this means
the minister for information technology
energy the mayor of
stockholm the
chairman of the regulator and of course
our president who is also swedish they
all were happy to come and
those who followed the
fdh conferences in the past know
in countries where fiber adoption is not
that popular
it's strange to pull it politicians the
decision makers they hide they don't
want to go on stage which is a pity and
so today it was really a strong message
i think to the whole of europe saying
we are proud about fiber and we are
proud that
we can showcase how we use fiber to make
sweden and the nordic countries really
future looking countries
do you think it's possible to get the
other countries in europe to to learn
from this
this is our mission so that's why we
also brought the conference here we do
our best to convince the decision makers
the those who are in the governments to
understand the real impact of fiber and
of course it's a mission that will take
still many years because i believe it's
also a generation problem
we shouldn't forget many of the
politicians that are sitting in
parliament in europe still have a
secretary printing out the emails
because they don't want to touch
touch anything
so and convincing them that the future
looks different
is a bit of a of a tedious
work but on the other hand if you look
at young people young ministers
talking about ana karen hat the minister
this morning or i met
some times ago the
french minister for information
technology is also a very young young
person they understand it and they know
how to move it forward and this is what
we as an fddh council want to push we
want to showcase these are the good
examples and if you make a decision we
have defects we have the figures and we
have the models for it so that it's not
just a
vague thingy it will change the world
it's really something where we can make
a decision based on facts and figures at
the end is it easier nowadays to reach
out with a message like this for the
politicians i mean for many politicians
it has always been
a matter of cost to invest in fiber
um
i would say it's still a challenge so
they are
let's say the other way around because i
always need to say if we talk about
europe we have not one single market we
have 28 different markets and we have
markets where it is easy to get these
messages out like the nordic ones where
we are in at the moment and there are
others
where we really need to do still a long
work and a long way to go until they
realize it's necessary not to do small
steps not to follow the incumbents
doing small upgrades and then saying
that we'll work for the next two years
and after the elections we look for for
the next solutions but to make a
visionary a statement saying
let's go this direction and
our president used a very nice sentence
saying
you shouldn't do these small steps you
should do it once and you should do it
right and that's fiber yeah
were there anything more said this
morning which is uh
which we should take up here i think one
one other topic which is important for
europe and which was stressed by several
of the speakers is the
topic of inclusion
inclusion meaning some people call it
digital divide
making sure that everyone gets fiber not
just specific people in a big city in a
in a specific region but to make sure
that everyone gets fiber like they get
electricity like they get
gas gas and water to ensure it's a basic
infrastructure you need to be connected
because just imagine you do an
e-government
solution and suddenly
20 of the people are disconnected from
this democratic process because
sorry your connection is not good enough
or
there is a healthcare system that really
supports your staying at home longer and
then if you would like to do this the
people have to tell yeah sorry you're
living in an area where it's not
possible because you don't have the
fiber connection and this
has a very big social impact and we at
the fddh council we really take this
serious and we even say
already several times we believe that
it's a political decision to make
now
if you want to have a europe of
prosperous regions or europe of mega
cities
because
young people need the infrastructure and
if we only build it in cities then the
people will go to them and
we believe it is not impossible to build
a highway
into every small city it is not possible
to connect every municipality with a
high-speed train
but it is possible and it's affordable
to connect every single european
household with fiber some people talk
about at least here in sweden they're
talking about it mobile you only need
the mobile connection
this is wonderful we love mobile and i
really have to make this statement again
we love mobile the reason is this is
complementary so
mobile connection and fixed connections
are not competing each other if you are
at home and you want to do video on
demand services you want to have a 4k
video streaming you want to do high
speed uh teleworking you need a fixed
line yeah but of course if you're moving
around with our tablet smartphones all
of us need the the mobile connections
plus and that's the important thing
the more mobile users you have the more
fiber you need because many people
forget if you have a base station
it's a shared connection so
if you want to make sure that everyone
gets at least 20 30 megabit which is not
too much anymore then you need to have
hundreds of base stations in a small
area and now guess you need to connect
them somehow and that's with fiber
and just to give you an idea right this
can even go
the other direction
if you look at our statistics
it's not europe at the moment but nearly
turkey is
surprisingly one of the countries that
adopted to fiber very strongly in the
last years
the story behind it is that turk cell
that's a
mobile operator and all of you whoever
have been in turkey on holiday they
immediately have this as the main mobile
operator on their smartphones they said
yes we want to do a lte rollout so they
did the planning they looked at how can
we make sure it's a real serious one not
just a hundred megabits yet but 200
people and you you have nothing at the
end and they realized the best way to do
it is
having base stations nearly on every
second or third house
and then they realized if we do this
it's just a small additional investment
to make fibo to the home yeah and so
they founded a subsidiary called
superonline
who just made use of this plan and sold
fiber to the home connections in
addition
and it was successful so super online
has a lot of fiber connections and at
the same time turxell is selling the lte
connections and this gives a bit of a
feeling that it's not competitive it's
really something that is uh
perfectly fitting together so the mobile
operators can actually drive your
business
indeed and uh it's even also the other
way around we heard this from the mayor
of stockholm this morning one of the
reasons why stockholm has
i believe the best coverage on lte
worldwide
is the fact that fiber is available
because the mobile operators could very
easily build up their infrastructure in
base stations to make a great coverage
of
a fiber here in this region
so it's really a win-win situation for
both sides and this is really something
we as an ftdh council say this is great
we just warned the decision makers and
the politicians
to do
the wrong step that some people do today
saying yes you know for the rural areas
mobile connection is the perfect
solution because and it happened in
germany for example you just put one lte
base station in the middle of the city
of the municipality or the village and
then you can say
we have 100 megabit
the next day
40 people subscribe to it and in the
evening hours if all the 40 people
connect to 100 megabit you don't need to
meet a mass genius to say okay then two
to three megabit is the maximum you get
and the problem is then of course
because it was publicly supported it was
with a strong push if then these people
go back to the decision makers and say
can you please
make sure we get something better than
that they say sorry we just helped you
come back in seven years and then we
helped you again and now you see we come
back to the digital divide story which
is the one where we say we need to make
sure everyone gets the full connection
at the end
yeah
talking about this event
is there anything any special
seminar or something you want to
lift up for the audience
this uh did there is always the thing
all of them are good so
for footing for some i mentioned already
some like the the e health one uh there
is one uh
session tomorrow in the in the afternoon
where we will present the
results of a study that we did with end
users
i don't want to tell too much now
because this will will come later on
with the analyst himself but what we did
is we said let's ask
in sweden because here we have it fiber
users and non-fiber users how happy they
are with the connection
and
we were really neutral and said whatever
is the result let's look at it and be
very impressed to see that fiber users
are really happy people in a way that
they say
they want have the fiber they want to
keep the fiber and they're really
satisfied with what they get
and if you ask the same thing to
the typical dsl copper
users it is significantly lower they are
really
saying we have big problems with the
connection speed and
there's a lot of people who said if i
would have the chance to go from copper
to fiber i would do it
but
many of them can't because it's not
available and i think that's also a good
message for the operators because
there's always the discussion is the
demand outside will the people really
need it
there is the demand you just need to
offer it and market it the right way and
then of course give the people the
chance to adopt to it but if you get a
critical mass and that's maybe just the
second session where i could say that's
a really of interest
it's today in the evening
the session about market data
it's the tradition that here at the
conference we show the latest update on
the fdh market and also the forecast and
then we have a panel with all the global
councils discussing and on the forecast
the analyst from heavy reading he has a
very interesting approach he says a
country is mature on fiber
if it reaches 20 percent of homes
connected
and the idea behind this this is let's
say the first 20
uh you need to adopt and then if you
have 20 percent of people using fiber
the dynamic that the others want it and
adapt to it and also the operators
realizing wow
there is a demand for it is coming very
easily and that's i think it's a good
message
thank you very much for coming heartrick
it's a pleasure and
have fun and enjoy the conference here
thank you thank you very much
and uh to all of you viewers uh if you
want to see the whole show see the whole
seminar you can log in at
ftthconference.edu
uh registered there
and with me now i have uve
the ceo of skanova the swedish
largest network owner i think
yeah that's right that's right
you're you're a very special person i
mean you're not only
you're not only the ceo of the over the
in the company in a small part of the
the the former incumbent you're also
actually a fiber optic scientist well i
started off my career with uh
trying to be research in optics and
optical sensors because when i started
in 80s we saw the future of fiber and
fiber optics so that was really an area
that i was devoted to but after a couple
of years as a researcher i wanted to
change the direction and work totally
with
people and more technical systems and
the change of society instead so so i
changed career and i'm very happy with
that
so
does the
society look like you thought it would
be look like when you were working as a
scientist well we understood earlier
that the
fiber is the solution ultimate solution
for telecommunications all the way to
the houses but we couldn't see the
future of the demand really so that
that's what we have been waiting for for
some decades now but now we have the
demand and then the demand river and
fiber roll out so i think the society
you can never predict the development of
society but what is happening now you
couldn't even predict a couple of years
ago so i think it's fascinating part of
that development
you are one of the main
fiber net
owners here in sweden
what development do you see i mean
you're investing heavy in fiber to the
home
these days
are the demand
growing
well we have i think a very unique
situation in sweden in two ways one is
the competition on the network layer
because we are not the only one building
fiber network
we are only building a passive layer in
in my company but we have around 200
players in sweden building fiber
networks
and that's a lot for a country of 9
million inhabitants to have that many
fiber operators and that's very unique i
think and also what we have in sweden
now is a very high demand of services uh
actually the change of behavior the
consumer is actually helping out because
it's not true you can just build a
network and you will get your money back
you have to have customers that would
like to pay for the services
and we have that in sweden and that's
helping out thanks to that willingness
to to have new services they pay for it
we actually we all that we are investing
in sweden are investing more and more
and
see the future in the business even as a
long-term investment
we can actually see that we will get our
money back
yeah but it sounds really strange i mean
the swedish people must be made of money
i mean they're paying they're paying a 2
000 euro up front yeah
to get their the fiber into the home
then they're paying uh 50 euro a month
for something for for having
access within the
this and then they pay for services like
tv and
gaming and modules and stuff like that
but you can also see it as an investment
for the family because if you
pay a one-time fee or two thousand euros
to get fiber into your own house the
value increases of your house it
actually so in in sweden and in
stockholm particularly i know stories
about families that are going to buy a
new house
and if the new house don't have fiber
the children will not join the parents
look at the house even because
you have to have a fiber to have an easy
sale process nowadays is this a
generation question i mean you're
talking about children bringing the
demand there yeah it could be uh of
course uh children are maybe the the
first one to adopt to a new way of
living and for example if you look at
the broadcast tv
many people even in my generation
use media streaming as a compliment to
broadcast tv but in young generation
they don't watch broadcast tv at all
they only watch streaming media and of
course then you need better broadband
capacity
uh preferably through fiber to see that
what are the big issues when building
fiber in the nordics i mean
most people viewing this they are living
in central and southern europe
i guess
they have much easier way to dig in the
ground stuff like that
well we have problems with the
usually strong and cold winters even if
this winter is so far a mile winter so
it's many months we can't do anything
because it's a frozen ground uh
otherwise i think
it's very very expensive to dig in the
ground and build a network
and then so we are very dependent on the
local authorities municipalities that
they have a good cooperation with us so
we can actually use new methods get the
cost down and then we can reach more
people
with broadband so i think uh
the digging cost and and uh
taking care of the streets afterwards
with asphalt and things i think that's a
great portion of cost and if you can do
that in a better way we can do a lot
more in sweden the local authorities are
are they willingness to do this
or are
they hard to get well you can't say yes
or no because we have 290 local
municipalities in sweden and they act in
290 different ways
some of them of course have their own
city networks some of them are dependent
than we or other actors are building
fiber networks some of them are very
keen that we will get there and then
help them to build fiber networks and
and they are very good in helping us to
get the costs down and we can do more
for the for them and the inhabitants in
that geography but others are are not
doing that because they would like to
have maybe new roads and things like
that
so so it's a very big difference between
between them how they act okay so so but
but that must cost a fortune for you to
i mean
to cooperate with 290
local authorities yeah but that is the
situation we have here in sweden and
it's very important to have this uh
relation with the local authorities in a
good way and since we have a carbon
network called oversweden we have some
relations already and
it's also up to us to behave in a good
way and to be a good part of the society
when we act
we have a real strong strong competition
here in sweden as well
we have
the old incumbent which is you
we have eqt which is a risk capital
company
and we have all these local
networks
owned by local
governments local parts of the country
how do you
compete in the market well
first of all i could say that i think
it's very good to have competition
because
it drives us to perform better and
have new ideas how to perform even
better in the future so i think
competition is good it's good for us
it's good for our suppliers and good for
our customers also to
really support competition uh but on
equal terms preferably um but for
example you mentioned a company that's a
venture capitalist and i think that's
interesting to see that they are
investing in this also because they
wouldn't do it if we couldn't see there
was a good future in good business doing
this so that's why i'm saying that we
are doing the right thing here in sweden
building a lot of fiber of course so so
it
encourages us to to continue and maybe
to speed up a little bit of course
do you think this competition will will
uh
be be good for sweden
yeah i think probably we have reached
the position
that we have today thanks to competition
and the high demands from the customer
i think there are two factors that
actually have put us in the top of the
the league regarding fiber so i think
that's very good for the country
is there any possibility for you to say
any number about how many homes i mean
you're building fiber to the home how
many homes do you
do you actually
come into every year
well depend on how you count because in
sweden you have to to understand that
roughly half of the population
live in a multi-dwelling units apartment
buildings and roughly half in private
houses in vilas
and we have in speed and we have built a
lot of multi-dwelling units over the
last decade
with a lot of fiber so so what we are
talking about now we mainly continue
with fiber to their houses ftdh to the
single houses
and and we are doing a lot and we had
200 city networks are doing a lot but
last year
i think it was more than 60 000
houses
and
we are trying to speed up a little bit
but it's very expensive and it takes
time
is it possible to speed up
well it's a matter of resources and
because you need to have technicians out
there in the field
that are doing this and we would like to
build with quality because the network
that we are building should last for
like 20 30 40 years
so so we don't want to speed up and lose
quality so so keep the quality and speed
up and see what we can do
is there anything we in sweden can learn
from the other countries coming here i
mean you're walking around at this event
and looking at
different seminars do you learn anything
from this well for example we are
talking a lot of fiber all the way but
since sweden is a very sparsely
populated country we will probably have
to use some other technologies also in
the toolbox to provide a good broadband
experience for all the so we are looking
into what can you do with the kappa
network can you speed it up you in the
history you have with ads lvds and now
g.fost maybe that will be technologies
that we can use in some areas in sweden
and in some areas probably
you have to have mobile solutions
because if you live out in the forest
and maybe have tens of kilometers to the
nearest village
of course you can't have fiber but on
the other hand i mean you have fiber in
the
the part of sweden called westerbottom
which is
almost on top of sweden if you watch the
swedish map it's almost on top and the
population up there it's
less people than in sahara
yes exactly in those areas in sweden we
have project that you might call a
fabricator village project when actually
the the people by themselves form some
organization and maybe do the digging
themselves and
spend a lot of time themselves helping
out and in those areas they will
probably get fiber at a lower cost than
if you live in a suburb to stockholm but
you have to do a lot more work yourself
and you will see that also but it's not
that all the people in sweden are
willing to do that work by themselves of
course there will be areas where
actually people provided with a good
mobile broadband instead and
as you know they're building a lot of
mobile broadband network in sweden right
now so
there will be also support for the
people out in the countryside and
support for the fiber networks i guess
we were talking with hartwig from fdtih
council yeah exactly
because it used to be so people
discussed
a couple of years ago should it be a
mobile network or a fixed network and
the answer now is both of course if you
build up a fiber network and give people
very good broadband experience in their
homes that actually drives mobile
broadband
connections because the people would
like to have that good service when they
are on the move also
he made an example of turkey where there
they found out the market after bringing
fiber out to the mobile base stations
and then they could start to build out
to the houses in in the near area is
that the way you're working here as well
well i think when you when you are
building fiber it's very expensive so
what you have to do is look at your
geographical area and see what kind of
other customers can you find for your
fiber network could be mobile base
stations
it could be companies not only
consumer segments so you have to look at
all the demands you have in the
geography and try to meet those amount
at the same time so you get your return
on investment in a better way
yeah but that i think the swedish
government have a goal set up for 90
percent of people being connected to 100
megabit uh
within uh the year 2020 they think we
will be able to reach that target well
first of all i think the the exact
wording is not connected have the
possibility to connect
what is important actually perhaps is
strong demand in sweden and actually
people buy the connection because they
don't buy it it's not used building that
network but so far so good
um but i think um 90
it's a tough challenge since we have the
situation in sweden we have with a large
country and only 9 million inhabitants
so it will be tough at the end so so
maybe you will see if you reach 90
percent or a little bit less but i think
it's a good goal it's a good target for
the country and but also had to look
into different other technologies
to to reach 19 and to reach 100 because
if you don't have 100 megabit maybe
you're satisfied with 16 megabit
could be so so
but i think it's very important to to
have all the people in sweden to have a
good communication because i must ask
you
actually
in in
seven years time
would you
do you think you would
hang on to only a 60 megabit
connection
well it's a lot of people now that
doesn't even have one megabit today so i
think 60 maybe it could be maybe a good
solution but at the same time you have a
good mobile coverage and the mobile
network seven years from now but
probably provide a lot more than 60
megabit but the question was yes would
you be
happy with 60 megabits i'm not sure of
that because i have fibre myself and i
can see what i'm doing at home so of
course yes when you get
used to 100 megabits then you're not
going to down the grade again
that's for sure
you're
around here watching the event um
what are you planning
for the rest of the event well what are
you planning to do what are there any
special seminars you're going to watch
today well i'm a little bit keen on
what's happening in the market what are
the trends technology trends trans new
services
and i think you learn a lot just going
around talking to people and a lot of
people would like to talk to to us from
sweden and other countries so you're not
going to any specific specific seminar
after this
just walking around them
go into some seminars regarding the
market update for example later today i
will go to and see what is the situation
right now
it used to be so that the nordic baltic
and the eastern europe countries are
leading this ftdh race is it still so or
is it any more western europe countries
that are doing things
and so i will look into that to see what
is happening really and of course new
technologies you always have to look
into what is happening on the market
okay over thank you very much for coming
to our studio okay thank you
and we will continue
our broadcast
as you can see now the people are still
eating lunch
as i told you earlier we
you have the possibility to watch the
whole conference
in our live streams
so just log in at ftth europe.eu
and now with me i have two new people
and these are the researchers we've
heard a little bit about earlier it's
benoit felton welcome hello from
diffraction analysis yes
and it's thomas caldenos i minds indeed
welcome to our studio thank you so much
you're having a seminar tomorrow i've
heard where you are going to uh reveal
some exciting things yeah yeah
it's true
tomorrow we have a seminar which we call
the the fiber the business model
uh
it's a process of trial and error
and i think the reason for the title is
that we're looking more to actually
getting field experience right so you
know we're going to talk around not the
theoretical business modeling a bit
but mainly you know what can we learn
from getting our hands dirty yeah
testing our ideas with users with
applications and you know really
synchronize it with the market so i
think that's kind of the red line for
that session okay
so uh what will you reveal i mean
have anything happen
to begin with the first question were
you shocked about
what you saw when you got the numbers
well so just to clarify uh
the the the user feedback is one part of
the business model okay so that's the
part that i'm going to be showcasing
there are other aspects which thomas
will probably talk about uh some more
um i don't know if shocked is the right
word but surprised certainly
what we were trying to do is was
essentially two things first as far as
we were aware
these kinds of numbers never existed
publicly in other words service
providers very probably did this kind of
study for their own needs but no one did
a broad
study to try and understand and share
with the rest of the industry what was
happening
the second thing is that we decided to
do these numbers for sweden because
swedish is a mature market and of course
if we want to see long-term trends
in this industry we have to look at a
market which has already uh to a large
extent adopted uh ftth as a solution oh
yeah um
but even taking that maturity into
account yes we were surprised by a
number of the results and to be honest
quite excited oh yeah pleasantly
surprised yeah
and now you make me really
yeah there are actually several studies
i mean what benoit will talk around is
if you compare copper and fiber okay and
you will see the i'm not sure really but
but you will see significant differences
between the usage between copper and
fiber users we heard actually hartwig
tauber from ftth council just a little
bit earlier here saying that uh
people with fiber are more happy than
people without fiber and
that will that will make me a much
happier person in within six months with
my operator are keeping their word as as
a as an analyst i i wouldn't have used
the word happy to me happy people is an
rem song first and foremost but um
but uh no what we see is very clearly
that the level of satisfaction with
broadband is massively higher for
uh for ftth users than it is for dsl
users what's the reason behind that
oh um well
in a nutshell
what we see from our data and we're
going to show the numbers tomorrow that
back that is that
dsl users are frustrated they realize
that they're paying roughly the same
price for a product that is just not as
good and in fact in some instances
according to what they tell us not good
at all
and and so um
the maturity of the market as we
understand it through those numbers is
really that even people who are not on
fiber understand the benefits of fiber
and i think that's
the difference with markets where fiber
is less present
and basically
users have not
it's not gotten into their consciousness
that there is a really
better
i mean tangibly better solution out
there
and so that's to me the really
interesting thing because quite often
when you talk about sweden in the rest
of europe people will say oh yes but
that's sweden
yeah what we want to uh highlight
through the study is that this is a
continuity
it's not that sweden is different it's
just the sweden is early oh yeah
and and to me that's a really important
uh point to stress that there is no
swedish exception there's just an early
adopter movement that started is there a
way to
i mean prove that well i think we can to
because
in addition to benoit's study we also
did one other study which we're going to
talk around and that's why we checked
what happens if you give people fiber
and that was done in the flemish part of
belgium so we checked the behavior
before fiber and after fiber okay so you
could really see the usage pattern
changing dramatically once you put fiber
in the hands of the users
and that's the other side because you
take a snapshot of the swedish example
right now we followed users for three
years three years to understand what
happened before and after and
it's also very exciting results and
quite complimentary actually
yeah
so
i'm excited about that
and they're not contradicting each other
and you haven't told they told each
other
my story i haven't seen his story
okay
so thomas you've seen uh
study and you're half swedish so
well i'm actually i'm here fully swedish
but i don't live in sweden anymore
that's true but yeah it's very exciting
uh
i'm specifically well i can't reveal all
the pattern but there's something about
how fibre is being used both upload and
download which is really telling me
something about how applications will
develop
in the future
also having you know a cloud and having
fiber and the complementarity between
these technologies so i want to spin
more on that in the conference or in the
session tomorrow because there is
something about upload and download
which changes both of them oh yeah so
it's it's not
and that's also part of our study i mean
we really changed the way we start using
internet it's it's not just more right
more is absolutely in there oh yeah it's
not just more it's different as well
okay stuff
when you have fiber or at least if i
stick to my own study
people who have fiber do stuff that
people who don't have fiber don't do
right and uh what do you mean with that
well so for example when you look at uh
at applications things that people do
online you see that for all of the
common stuff social networking email
there's no difference between the
samples right but for a lot of the more
advanced stuff like doing video
communication or e-learning there's a
massive difference right so
ftth users
are much more mature in their usage not
just in the amount of usage but in what
they do
they they embrace
uh
more
let's say leading-edge applications
that dsl users simply don't okay so so
and
sure some of these applications require
more bandwidth but others don't
it's so it's not just about the fact
that you have more capacity it's also
that it opens you up because you have
more capacity it opens you up to a lot
of different things that you would not
have looked at otherwise there's a very
interesting
result from our study where we tested a
number of
let's say when i say futuristic i don't
mean 20-year but like two or five years
so service concepts that are not quite
in the market yet but we already know
what they're going to look like and we
tested interest we said you know if your
service provider was to offer this
service to you would you be interested
and for all of these services every
single one fth users are much more
interested than dsl users so that also
means that as a service provider you are
creating the platform
for future revenues
but this is this for all generations i
mean the younger people of course they
they want to they're keen to try
everything out so you're absolutely
correct that there is a generational gap
uh and in fact the differences between
dsl and ftth are not as high
in the less than 35 year old year olds
than they are in the above 50 let's say
but even overall having said that
there's still more appetite from ftth
users
to me what we saw from our study is that
the sheer speed the capacity of fiber
network provides different user
experience
it's a bit like if you have an iphone
and you compare to your old phone which
was sloppy and slow suddenly everything
works just like charm right and that
experience in itself is fantastic for
users and once they have it they never
want to go back oh yeah fiber is very
sticky
i mean i actually never heard anyone who
has fiber wants to go back to dsl have
you no no
but that's also the marketing dilemma
right you must experience it because
once you've seen what it is you want to
don't want to go back but how can you do
that how can you actually promote it in
that way
if i was to add i mean we always have to
be careful with analogies because we end
up talking about
cars or pizzas or highways instead of
talking about broadband but
it's a little bit like if you get a
faster car
you don't just go faster on the highway
you go to places you wouldn't have gone
to if you if you only had your slow car
so it it takes you to other
experiences and and and that to me
is a big part of why they don't want to
switch back because they realize
absolutely
that
going through these experiences on an
inferior platform
would be painful so people people in
europe they should should get stickers
to get on their houses on the doors i
have fiber and also maybe
i wish they did
i would certainly tattoo it on my
forehead if i had fiber but i can't use
the fiberglass
so i hope you don't touch your dsl into
your forehead
that's an old one
are there any other
parts from the study you can reveal here
um
the the uh the interesting thing
and
it's something you have to start kind of
massaging the numbers and digging to
really make it come out
when we first looked at it we had this
strange sense that
people who had dsl
said it wasn't very good
it was too expensive
but the migration the intentions for
migration weren't high
so that puzzled us we thought well if
you're not happy with your solution
surely
there's got to be a reason why
you don't want to change
and when we started looking into it what
came out quite clearly is that nearly
half of the dsl users
can't change
either because there's no fiber where
they are
or because they're locked in a contract
that doesn't allow them to change
and i mean imagine this is 45
of the established dsl customer base
wants fiber but can't get it
so that's both a negative of course but
it's also a positive because it means
that
quite often fiber gets deployed in the
areas where the most revenue is going to
be made first right
and so inevitably when you're deploying
the network there's a point where you go
uh should i go any further well this
tells us that if you go further the
demand is still there in fact it might
even be higher because they're
frustrated
they they want it i mean 10 years ago
people who got it didn't necessarily
know what they were getting no now they
know it exists and they can't have it
that's the best kind of demand so it's
quite exciting to us because
we we talk again and again and it's kind
of the purpose of this session tomorrow
that the business model is hard and it
is
right but a big question mark around
that business model is demand
uncertainty
will the demand be there yeah and what
this tells us is in a mature market the
demand is absolutely there and it's not
just the first 30 percent or the first
50 of the population so that's very
exciting because it means service
providers
have a business model of course they
need to execute it properly and in fact
one of the things i often say as an
analyst is a lot more projects fail on
execution than they fail on
strategy or even the business model um
but if they can get the execution right
the business is there which is an
interesting point because that tells us
a bit on how we should deploy the fiber
network right because one school of
thought is that you deploy to those who
ask for it yeah
which is the short-term vision but once
you need to deploy to the second
generation it comes with a huge cost
unless you deployed it in a way where
you can hook up them in a cheap way
right so that's the question how do you
build this passive expensive
infrastructure to actually make the
optional costs to hook on new customers
as low as possible given that we
actually think there is demand but it's
not yet really captured
uh so it's also bringing down to know
the the actual revenues and the costs of
building a fiber network which is you
know in all fairness there are four
sessions right it's not only about this
year's experience we're also going to
talk around you know how do you deploy
it in a smart way okay so um but how do
we deploy it in a smart way then why
well that's
i can't claim that i have it but one
thought i think and we should discuss
this more probably that session is also
this passive infrastructure should be
there for 78 years right yeah and it
they will at least have to serve three
or four generations of active
technologies you know we have to point
the point deep on today what's coming
next we can discuss that but this
infrastructure has to stay in place and
it must be able to serve more
technologies than we have today so
question is how we build such an
infrastructure in a kind of i hate the
word future proof but at least prove to
some extent in the future
so that that's also another discussion
which comes out of this together with
how do you hook up customers in the
second wave
yeah yeah
a discussion we have had earlier today
here in our studio is
the fact that the swedish people
are paying about 2 000 euro up front to
get their connection into the fiber
connection into their house yeah
uh
have you i'm not surprised you're not
surprised why not well i'm not surprised
essentially for two reasons the first
one is once you want it
you weigh things completely differently
if you are not sure and someone comes
and says you have to pay 2 000 euros you
hesitate of course or you even say
that's ridiculous yeah you can spend two
thousand euro on the new so far at the
moment
or something but let's be clear you're
paying those 2 000 euros anyway right
this is exactly like mobile phone
subsidies
if you're buying your mobile phone your
iphone you're paying 500 euros or
whatever the cost is these days um
you're paying 500 euros and of course
your subscription is going to be lower
because it's already paid for
so this is similar but there's another
reason and this is something we
highlighted last year in a study that we
did for the fibers to home council and
that is that
increasingly and i think here in sweden
very much so because of maturity
customers know
that having fiber in their house
increases the value of their house so
it's not just that they want it it's
also that they understand that
financially they're not it's not money
they're throwing out of the window it's
money that they're investing in their
house it's a bit like refurbishing your
house right you could argue that you can
perfectly live in a in a horrible
looking house
but you do it because you know that if
you're gonna resell it first you do it
because you want to live in a nice house
but also you know that if you want to
resell your house it's going to increase
the value of your house and this is
exactly the same thing and and
as
so one of the questions that and i don't
want to give you the exact results
because it's quite exciting but um
but one of the questions that we asked
in in the questionnaire we did was what
are your key criteria when you're
choosing a new home
and all i can tell you is for ftth users
broadband comes way higher than we
expected oh yeah
which means that the value that is
attached to that
is quite clear to them oh yeah
which has been confirmed i mean there
was a new study some years ago when the
recession was going on and they asked
what would you give up first and last
and they would you know stop going to
the cinemas stop going out eating stop
traveling but they keep the fiber oh
yeah yeah that's you know really sticky
once you have it you don't want to give
it up
but can you say the same trend down in
the flamish
uh well
not that you have a whole lot of fiber
there we don't have so much fun with
that
that's true well there's not an option
there
that's
dsl land i'm afraid
we have very good dsl i have say vdsl
too so it's not you know it's also also
very good quality dslr compared to what
you have in sweden so the the the
difference is slighter but you know they
i also see some trends of going more to
fiber to dome even in the flemish part
of belgium oh yeah
but but um
is it possible to export i mean export
the facts
export the knowledge to the rest of
europe that
you need to invest in your house the
fiber
on investment it seems like the rest of
europe hasn't seen that yet no and and i
think i mean interestingly enough
i think the awareness here has not been
structured
it's not
uh i remember the first time i came to
stockholm to talk about fiber
uh this was back in 2008. i met with a
real estate owner
who owned a number of
apartment blocks for students
and he said to me a few years ago
in october november time when we assess
the proportion of apartments that have
been rented we found out that two of our
buildings were way below the others
like 30 below the others and i couldn't
understand why
and when we started looking into it we
found out that these two were the two
that didn't have fiber
so
for a real estate guy if you see numbers
like that you don't need anyone to tell
you that there's value it's absolutely
evident right so i think here in sweden
it happened organically
in the rest of europe
if these things can be highlighted
uh if they can be structured in a way
that real estate players even when the
fiber has not been deployed understand
the benefits then it will accelerate
things because suddenly they will be
willing participants to that ecosystem
which is not really the case today for
them it's a non-topic or a very
peripheral topic
it's not a core topic but one of the
things that
my company is working on and we don't
have definitive results yet but uh we're
working on an analysis of home prices in
the netherlands
over the last six years
and this is in partnership with a dutch
company called stratix that tracks ftth
coverage on a city-by-city basis
and what we want to do is we want to
establish if there's a correlation
between the fact that fiber has been
deployed in the city and the way home
prices have evolved oh yeah because if
we can show that there's a correlation
it suggests that
the market is aware of the value even if
it's not
big discourses and
you know a structured approach but users
are aware of it and again i don't want
to promise results it's looking
promising so far but we haven't gotten
to the point where we can conclusively
say that's the case but i hope it is
because it's something we have suspected
for a long time and
we do need to have these numbers out
there so that in other countries real
estate people can look at this and say
i'm missing out on something yeah
and i think we need to create that
awareness campaign actually to spread
that word because
that may not be understood by everyone
in europe that's absolutely true and i
think that's the role of of
organizations such as the ftth council
to actually
you know talk as an industry as opposed
to us individuals as influent as we
might think we are
there's a limit to our reach
um i mean if i look i mean if i look how
they did it in the u.s verizon for
example they had this fantastic
marketing campaign where they had a
fiber bus
moving around talking about they had
kind of these home parties where they
went home you know i would like to have
this sell plastic stuff right fiber home
parties to talk about the benefits of
fiber that's marketing oh yeah i also
have background in marketing so you know
you can be very creative when it comes
to creating awareness i think we're
still a bit you know technical when it
comes to this
so certainly being in the marketeers and
create awareness so that's that's one of
the solutions for the ftth industry to
be better on marketing well i would
certainly argue that i think
i mean as important as
technology and financing are in this in
this whole process
i think uh when i look at failures or at
least struggling projects it's never on
those too
it's always on marketing selling finding
the right offers i think there's a lot
of legacy thinking still in this
industry
so
this discontinuity between copper and
fiber is not always perceived even by
the operators who launched the fiber
and especially when they own copper
assets as well
they
they don't really
market the fiber
to
highlight how different that experience
is because they're worried that it's
going to hurt their copper operations
and so it creates a continuity which
makes it very hard to market because
selling something better is always
harder than selling something new or
revolutionary oh yeah yeah of course and
so uh i mean a lot of the work that i do
with my customers is assisting them in
accepting
you know where can we be disruptive and
how do we need to do it so that users
get it
like that yeah
and it's tough but that's where the
reward is yeah and
you know anyone who's run a business
model and i don't think thomas will
contradict me on this knows that the
difference between
30 take-up and 35 take-up financially is
enormous yeah absolutely and sometimes
it's the difference between failure and
success just that five percent of
takeoff and yet i see operators who
don't want to offer too much because
well then how will i get more money down
the line and and i tell them guys if
this is five percent take up your money
is coming in now it's not coming in five
years so you know it's a long-term thing
but it's actually marred by a lot of
short-term thinking
does your study look anything into i
mean if you if these fiber companies
goes into an area there are several
people
choosing to have fiber and several not
choosing to have fiber
does this study see anything about
how jealous these
no no charge users are not at that
kind of very
localized level because
we would have needed a whole lot more
budget to be able to do a study like
that maybe you should do the study in
the year again well yeah sure but but
what i can tell you is this is going
back to this study that we showed last
year we talked to a real estate
developer in in the uk
that has
signed a project back in 2005
that had four different tranches
and the first tranche was uh basically
sold in 2008 and it had copper
and the next tranches were sold after
that and they all had fiber
and these guys there's a professional
company
customers don't even know who they are
they get phone calls every week from
people in the first tranche saying why
don't we have fiber please bring us
fiber
so i mean
neighbors are absolutely aware of it
yeah um
and
you were talking about the the home
parties the
cable in the 80s in the us did something
that was really smart uh which is that
in a neighborhood when they signed the
first customer
they would give him money to organize a
picnic
in his home and the only condition was
the tv had to be on all the time
and guys would go there eat the sausages
the hot dogs and flick the channels and
they go back home and they say darling
we need to have this thing oh yeah and i
think fiber
operators could do very much the same
kind of things
but they're not quite thinking in that
way yet and so you know it's a source of
frustration because they haven't quite
gelled to the fact that the marketing
needs to be different the selling needs
to be different all of these aspects of
the business model are just as important
as the rest right i i mean you can talk
a lot about marketing for a long time
but you know the best marketing is
word-of-mouth yeah you trust your peers
you don't trust people like us you trust
your peers and if your neighbor says
it's good you probably think it's good
as well
so if you can encourage that behavior
you can come a long way
and i also think that uh the
pure technology marketing has backfired
a few times you know with the mobile
broadband and whoop and that stuff which
was came out and the mms it really
didn't take off it was complex acronyms
people didn't realize what it was
so marketeers are a bit hesitant going
along that route but i think it's you
know time to actually promote fiber in a
peer-to-peer way yeah
i had a very brilliant question but i
just lost it okay
how long did you know how how long was
your story it was study it was made
during this
year it's very recent it's uh early
december of early last year so and how
much people did you
interviewed 400 people
300 on ftth and 100 on dsl and these
were all around sweden yes
yes
so
we've looked at a high level we didn't
reconstruct a
geographical sample because it didn't
really matter to what we were trying to
measure uh so the rule to
to
urban is probably the kind of natural
spread in the population yeah are you
planning to do
more studies like this so there is
discussion of uh actually
doing the same study in other countries
this year
to get some comparison basis and also
what i was talking about maturity so to
see
depending on how advanced you are on
that curve how different the perception
is
um so uh
so
i don't know if it's going to happen but
it's it's currently being discussed
will these studies uh
change anything do you think
i hope so otherwise i wouldn't have done
it
no no i i seriously hope so what's
interesting to me is that first
for people from other countries who are
looking at sweden and wondering if
what's happening here is replicable i
think this gives some clear answers it
also points at ways that you can measure
these things that maybe have not been
implemented in those countries
even for swedish players i think our
study brings in some really interesting
results about the next step
about the where the potential is coming
from from now on so it's not just enough
i think to say well sweden is a success
when it comes to fiber broadband because
what we see is there's still a whole lot
of potential
and that to me is really interesting
yeah
from us yeah will it change yeah we have
to spread the word but that's one thing
but another thing is
from a user perspective dance is clear
but then the underlying business model
you know and specifically think about
the fiber ecosystem is getting more and
more complex you have this open access
with several players you know
infrastructure active life so it's you
know there is also this competitiveness
which drives fiber in many cases and
sometimes
in countries where there is no
competition actually it doesn't happen
so
the mechanics of actually encourage the
the carriers to roll out fiber is is
another thing which can be encouraged by
these results of course but it's not
it's necessary but not enough i would
say
and there's also something we're going
to discuss in the session tomorrow you
know this multiplayer approach how we
can analyze it and show where
different deployment scenarios actually
make sense from a carrier perspective
yeah
so
what are you looking forward to watch
the rest of the show i mean we're almost
just in the beginning or in the middle
depending on how you count
i'm i'm chasing for field experience
right so field experience we're kind of
an academic organization so we're
looking for the real cases i'm looking
to people who have been digging and
deploying and experience out there so
have you found any seminars like that
here yeah absolutely but you just have a
coffee there and you i just had a coffee
with the
norwegian guys you know those who
encourage people to dig themselves oh
yeah it's you know it's a fascinating
story yeah we can learn a lot from that
yeah okay so um so i'm looking for field
experience and there's a lot of plenty
out here oh yeah
and you've benoit you're looking forward
for a special seminar well i have uh i
mean my company is is very international
and i mean we have customers literally
all over the world so what i'm after
really is is getting a better grasp on
some of these
uh experiences that you don't hear about
every day and this is this is a great
event because it attracts not just
people from europe but people from all
around the world so yesterday i found
out some really interesting stuff about
what's happening in indonesia in in
saudi arabia
and so you know what i'm after is these
little nuggets of
data and information about about these
countries and how fiber is um is
evolving in in those contexts yeah yeah
um to be honest with you i i haven't um
gone through the whole program with a
with a pencil to identify exactly who i
wanted to hear um
as an analyst i'm also here to meet my
customers or potential customers so you
have to juggle between the two but
whenever i have five minutes i i try to
hunt down
whatever is likely to be of interest but
the seminar you are having together it's
tomorrow yes tomorrow afternoon 2 30.
yeah quarter plus two maybe two o'clock
roughly yeah two o'clock roughly and uh
and it's going to be awesome people
really really need to it will change the
way you think about fiber
interesting thank you both for coming
thank you it's really interesting to
hear thank you for having your studies
thanks thank you very much
yeah and uh here we are at the floor of
stockholm smith
at the ftth council europe
2014.
my name is matt frudeen and i'm from
telecom new york which is a media
partner of
the ftth conference
and with me now i have paolo 7 welcome
thank you
you're working with smart cities
yes indeed
what uh
can you tell us more about smart cities
you had a workshop yesterday yeah
actually we had a cooking show
so
it was an experiment which uh
succeeded uh we tried to to cook
a smart city to cook a smart city this
yeah this sounds really i mean
oh you got me on the hook
okay ask
and now i'm really interested you must
tell me more
okay
how do you how do you do that
you know smart city is something
somehow new
and
it's something which has to do with
creativity
just like cooking
and you have a lot
of ingredients
which if you mix them in a different way
you get a different result
and that's exactly what we did yesterday
it's if you take the the
uh
an analogy to to to the kitchen
so in the smart in the city kitchen you
have different departments
so they all cook their own good food
the electricity department and and then
yeah
but okay it's good
but it might not be
new
and it might not be smart so
the the smart thing might lie between
the departments between the silas
and that was the idea to take the
ingredients
from the different silas
and mix them together in a different way
and look
what turns out
oh yeah so yeah and uh
did you get any results
yeah
for instance uh we had the
the smart home topic
and uh
we we draw a picture
about how our
home looks today and and
you can see on this picture a lot of
buyers
and
tons of remote control
and
data
everywhere and you forget the password
you have data on that cloud on that
cloud on your computer yeah
and
maybe on the storage system
and at the end of the day
you are confused yeah definitely i can
recognize myself in that yeah me too me
too
and so
even if the topic was smart home
at the end we came up with
we should have
a meta cloud
so you have only two to have one
password and through this metacloud you
access the different clouds so a cloud
which
gives like a middleware
access to to to the different
things you have around oh yeah it makes
so it started with smart home
and what came out was slightly different
but it definitely would make your life
easier and this is an important part of
smart cities
it's not just about technology no it's
about
making life easier for for the citizens
and for the companies for the key
stakeholders
and
sometimes we we forget
because we talk about technology
connecting and they're there yeah
but
yeah
but for the citizen
we have uh viewers from uh or at least
visitors here from at least 84 or 86
different countries yes uh
what i i'm not sure everyone knows what
the smart city is can you tell tell me
more about what what is the smart city
okay if you google smart city yeah
you will probably come up with
200 different terminologies yeah so in
other words there is no standard
for
what is smart
what we created as our terminology is
it should
have different components one is ecology
one is making life
easier you know for the citizens
uh one one is uh making the city more
efficient
and um
so these are the
uh
do you have to do
the telecom network brings things
together yeah so i mean you can do
better ecology by i mean
by connecting
what
might belong together yeah but you can
also sort your
garbage
out so
yeah yeah so so let's
let's make if if you if you're talking
about the garbage so we take this
example yeah
you go
the the the utility might go out every
day to collect the garbage yeah even if
there is no or not enough garbage you go
and you you create pollution
if you put sensors
or a camera or
something which
makes you know if
if you have to go or not
so you are optimizing the system
and you are saving
the
the city so the pollution yeah
and
the analogy we we make in this sense is
um
what does it mean being smart
so okay what does it mean become smart
it's another question
um
we
are smart at least i guess we think we
are smart human being
and
one
component of our infrastructure is the
nervous system
so
we believe that this is one of the main
reasons why we are smart
we have sensors
we get informations
we transport the
informations in real time and
symmetrical
and we make sense out of it
and if you want to turn
something else like a city
into a smart city
it's not that different
okay you need
a super fast symmetrical
nervous system yeah
and of course you need something which
is smart systems behind but
without
the nervous system
no senses
no infos
no reaction
no learning no action no
so just
silo thinking
like today yeah
so are there any cities who have come
further than others
when it comes to smart cities
there are different approaches and
of course barcelona
is one amsterdam
is one they had they have big
initiatives uh a lot of uh of projects
um i mean it's not like
uh turning
um a grown old city overnight into a
smart one so it you have to implement a
lot of smart projects
and you have to fail
yeah sometimes to become smarter yeah
can you give an example of what what uh
barcelona and amsterdam has done to to
to be smarter
so i i really knew approach in in
amsterdam and and uh i i was
astonished yesterday we had a gentleman
from uh he's advising amsterdam city oh
yeah
on the strategic way
and and so
they asked homeless people what their
need is in a smart city okay
yeah that's completely yeah okay and new
yeah
what what do you guess they they came up
with
i don't know better ways to to arrange
somewhere to sleep
yeah maybe
no it was about charging the mobile
phone
oh yeah yes
they have no place
where they can charge the mobile phone
of course and
even
they all not maybe not all but a lot of
them have mobile phones that are
connected
but they need to have access yeah
to uh to a power uh oh okay
yeah and so this was a small but uh
niche pro
project but okay it shows it's
considering
different stakeholders
and different needs yeah
so that was a good one yeah barcelona
i'm going to barcelona myself but sunday
so uh what should i look after when it
comes to smartness in barcelona i don't
know i don't know uh details about uh
barcelona unfortunately we we didn't
have uh people from barcelona yesterday
in the
but okay what they have in in common uh
they collaborate they are organized uh
also in
in
councils like
city protocol yeah
and
they exchange
their experience so if amsterdam does
something which is good or
something which fails
they communicate and they copy from each
other oh yeah so
and this is a good thing
and and the other thing it's that
increasingly now
bigger cities are engaging themselves in
in standards
because
otherwise
every city is inventing the wheel
the new wheel
and um
it doesn't really make
sense
so let's uh get smarter together that's
that's the approach
we're in sweden now uh do
sweden behind or in front of the others
or where in the middle of the pack
i i would say
um
you did your
or the swedish people
and the government did the home work
very very well
because a broadband
is everywhere yeah
so mobile broadband
and fiber to the home
and
this is the basis this is the the
nervous system and so and and
yeah talking in these terms uh
sweden is ahead
and we have the base layer at least yes
yes
and and of course several initiatives to
implement uh
new smart services
yeah yeah
so uh
talking about the rest of the conference
are you looking uh
looking ahead for any specific seminars
the rest of the conference here
to to be honest until now i was so busy
with the workshop and and
today i i did the moderation of uh smart
everything oh yeah topic yes but
everything you know
everything so now you have to tell me
more about the smart everything
i got you
not only the cities no it's everything
it's everything so we had a lady
maria she she's a ceo of a swedish
organization
and
they interconnect the
the universities
so
sweden it's pro has probably the best
connection in in in universities
one one gigabit yeah
so
and and um
yes we had a someone from a council
which
organizes a smart grid
topic yeah for the utilities
and
he was talking about the importance uh
of uh
of the grid in the future oh yeah so
because um
he made really a good analogy he said if
graham
bell
would show up
today
and you would show him um
a smartphone yeah he wouldn't recognize
recognize it no of course no no chance
because
it looks different
wire so no no chance for him and the
phone is just a small app within the
machine yes yes
but
if if you
if you would show
um
the
the great so so so the the power supply
uh
to someone who who lived 100
years ago
he probably would recognize it yeah
so it means
things didn't change a lot
over the
last 100 years
but
in 20 years he stated
they will not recognize the network
anymore
so and that's because everything goes
smart now
that's that's because
now the telecommunication field and the
id field is becoming
um
a critical success factor
for the the power supply of the future
oh yeah yeah if you if you think about
the
distributed
power generation
solar winds
you you name it
and
it becomes
increasingly
more difficult to to handle the grid
so and and uh the
consumer
uh today's consumer if they have a solar
in
installation on their roof uh they they
become a prosumer yeah so and and a
utility becomes
um
the manager of all these volatile things
and and also kind of a broker oh yeah so
if you are a prosumer you you have
something to sell yeah and something to
to buy yeah and so business cases will
will change
and
the power utilities if they use the
fiber
um
for for the core business i mean they
have fiber and they might also use it
for for other purposes like other
services
telecom or maybe being an enabler for
others to use their fibers yeah so
things are moving yeah yeah so now after
this session you're just going to relax
and
go out and uh
enjoy you've done your work so to say
yes yes i i will have a look and
if
yes probably if this interview would
would have been in in a few hours
i could tell you
what what i have seen but i i really
just went from one
place to another
paolo thank you very very much for
coming to our studio pleasure
thank you thank you goodbye and that was
all for this uh lunch broadcast at the
ftth conference here in
stockholm.com
we'll be back quarter to five with three
new more
people very interesting people all of
them i promise
thank you